[Aplausos]
[Música]
china es ya todo un coloso este país es
la mayor potencia comercial del mundo
[Música]
era el mercado mundial de cientos de
productos y cuenta con las mayores
reservas de divisas de todo el planeta
ni siquiera a las petromonarquías del
golfo pérsico pueden competir con este
gigante así no es extraño que muchos
analistas afirmen que muy pronto china
superará a los mismísimos estados unidos
como primera potencia económica claro
que con muchos más habitantes sin
embargo no solemos olvidar de un factor
importantísimo que el pib no lo es todo
y que el poder económico el poder de
verdad tiene una relación muy estrecha
con el poder empresarial y en ese
aspecto la verdad amigos china aún está
lejísimos de eeuu
y es que fijaos entre las 100 mayores
empresas del mundo hay 56
estadounidenses y tan sólo 11 chinas y
ojo porque esto no es ninguna tontería
las multinacionales controlan casi el 80
por ciento de las exportaciones
mundiales y de la inversión extranjera
pero ahora bien cuál es la verdadera
situación de las empresas chinas como
cambiando las cosas o qué podemos
esperar estas son algunas de las
preguntas que vamos a tratar de
responder en este vídeo vayamos a verlo
por cierto este vídeo es un tanto
especial pero de esto hablaremos más
tarde de momento os hago una pregunta
conocéis esta ciudad
[Música]
el desarrollo del gigante chino
la economía china ha tenido un
crecimiento impresionante en las últimas
tres décadas la clave la ha tenido el
siguiente concepto la fábrica del mundo
así es como se conoce a china un país
que ha conseguido convertirse en toda
una potencia y sacar a cientos de
millones de personas de la pobreza
gracias a una premisa fabricada de todo
a bajo coste juguete es electrónica
herramientas ropa cuando entramos en una
tienda podemos encontrar cientos de
productos diferentes con un denominador
común todos están fabricados en esas
impresionantes zonas industriales que
están repartidas a lo largo y ancho de
toda china
[Música]
sin embargo para que este país pueda
reclamar de verdad el puesto de primera
potencia económica del mundo sus
empresas tendrán que empezar a producir
cosas mucho más complejas tendrán que
dejar de competir en coste y embarcarse
en la búsqueda del valor añadido la
producción avanzada de cosas como bienes
de capital aviones equipos médicos o
procesadores de intel
en ecuador cuando ni en él
y de momento ya os adelanto que hoy
todos estos sectores están dominados por
las grandes multinacionales con sede en
eeuu corea del sur europa y japón
notamos a sí mismos
es verdad muchos productos de vanguardia
se producen en china por ejemplo los
iphone pero tiene truco porque la
aportación china se limita prácticamente
al ensamblado es decir las empresas
compran o producen en otros países las
piezas más complejas y luego las montan
en china para que os hagáis una idea
cada año china importa más de doscientos
mil millones de dólares en
semiconductores que son una parte
esencial en la fabricación por ejemplo
de equipos móviles esto es mucho más de
lo que gasta el país en petróleo eso sí
en los últimos años las empresas chinas
han hecho muchísimos avances hoy una
cuarta parte de todas las exportaciones
corresponde ya a bienes de capital como
máquinas por ejemplo o a productos de
alta tecnología
hay sectores como los de equipos de
telecomunicaciones turbinas eólicas y
trenes de alta velocidad donde las
empresas chinas son líderes mundiales y
no sólo eso
las empresas chinas están aprendiendo a
dar el salto a los mercados
internacionales
y la gran conquista china
[Música]
en 2016 se cumplió el 50 aniversario de
la revolución cultural una terrorífica
campaña con la que mahou quiso purificar
la revolución y terminar con las
facciones más aperturistas y pro
capitalistas tanto del partido comunista
como de la propia sociedad china pues
bien desde entonces las cosas han
cambiado mucho tanto que hoy china es el
segundo país del mundo con más
multinacionales sólo por detrás de eeuu
precisamente en este vídeo que hicimos
sobre la eurocopa os contamos que cada
vez se notaba más la presencia de
patrocinadores chinos prueba de que las
empresas de este país estaban empezando
a dar el salto a los mercados globales
pues vaya salto en 2016 las empresas
chinas se gastaron la increíble cifra de
225 mil millones de dólares en comprar
empresas extranjeras solo en europa y en
eeuu se registraron más de 450
operaciones de compras
tal como os cuento los chinos amigos de
visual política han comprado por ejemplo
el inter de milán y solo es un ejemplo
la compañía china rasta blue se hace con
el control del español eso sí si por
algo tienen especial predilección los
empresarios del gigante chino es por
invertir en países emergentes aunque
australia y eeuu son los dos principales
destinos de la inversión china más de la
mitad de toda la inversión extranjera
directa de este país se realiza en
países en desarrollo en países de áfrica
asia latinoamérica y el medio oriente
cuanto más riesgoso es el país más
dispuestos parecen los chinos a invertir
su dinero pero es que además las
empresas chinas están también empezando
a competir duro queréis una prueba pues
atentos si en 2006 sólo había una
empresa china entre las 100 marcas más
prestigiosas del mundo en 2015 ya eran
14 fijaos por ejemplo en algo que
conocemos todos de cerca la industria de
los smartphones hasta hace poco tiempo
tener un teléfono móvil de marca china
era como
un poco cutre verdad pues hoy los cuatro
principales fabricantes chinos o por
huawei vivo y jaume no es que se hayan
dado a conocer es que obtienen más del
10 por ciento de todos los beneficios de
la industria a nivel mundial y su peso
crece y crece otro ejemplo lenovo una
multinacional china que hace unos años
compró la división de portátiles de la
mismísima ibm hoy ya es la mayor empresa
de ordenadores de todo el mundo y
abastece de equipos incluso al propio
pentágono pero no digáis nada a trump
sensation side ertzaina chain a chain
zaira queréis aún más ejemplos pues los
hay de todos los colores ayer el mayor
fabricante de electrodomésticos del
mundo o coco una empresa que está
comprando montones de tierra por todo el
mundo ya sean campos de caña de azúcar
en australia viñedos franceses o
plantaciones de soja en brasil también
está
geely una empresa de coches que dará
mucho de qué hablar en los próximos años
y que en 2010 compró volvo sí volvo esa
mítica marca de coches suecos es de
propiedad china
[Música]
cómo cambian las cosas pero si hay un
sector donde china está tomando de
verdad la delantera es sorprendentemente
en internet
y digo sorprendentemente porque como
seguro sabéis la red en china está hiper
controlada y censurada por el gobierno
chino con lo que se llama el gran
cortafuegos que bloquea por ejemplo el
acceso a facebook google o the economics
por poner sólo tres ejemplos pues bien
en china lo normal es hacer casi todo a
través de aplicaciones del móvil por
ejemplo cuando vas a china y es muy raro
pagar con tarjetas pero muy habitual
pagar con el móvil a través de la mega
aplicación widget una super aplicación
que es como una especie de todo en uno
facebook paypal gmail twitter por cierto
muy chat pertenece harten send una de
las 15 empresas más valiosas de todo el
mundo que también es el mayor proveedor
mundial de juegos online y uno de los
mayores accionistas de tesla si los
chinos empiezan a estar en todas partes
queréis otro ejemplo de éxito sin duda
alibaba una empresa de comercio
electrónico que factura cada año más de
450 mil millones de dólares mucho más
que amazon e ivey juntas no está más
verdad solo en china tiene 400 millones
de clientes como dijo napoleón el día en
que china despierte el mundo temblará
pero tranquilos antes de echarnos las
manos a la cabeza pensar en todo lo que
esto puede suponer más competencia
mejores precios mejores productos un
desarrollo tecnológico más rápido vamos
que los consumidores nosotros podemos
sacar de este proceso muchos beneficios
claro que todo esto también puede tener
sus riesgos o al menos eso es de lo que
nos alertan las agencias de inteligencia
de eeuu la inteligencia de eeuu advierte
que las empresas chinas no son de
confianza y pide al gobierno federal
bloquear la compra de empresas
estadounidenses en sectores estratégicos
por parte de corporaciones chinas
y luego por otro lado también está el
riesgo para muchas de nuestras empresas
que van a tener aún mucha más
competencia aunque también oportunidades
como ya os conté en este vídeo eso sí
como se dice no vendamos la piel del oso
antes de cazarla las empresas chinas aún
están muy por detrás tecnológicamente y
además están súper endeudadas
los niveles de deuda corporativa en
china son demasiado altos y llevará
tiempo bajarlos a proporciones más
manejables tampoco olvidemos que china
es una dictadura y eso conlleva que el
gobierno tiene un excesivo peso en las
decisiones empresariales y el gobierno
es como todo órgano político arbitrario
e impredecible si hace unos años por
ejemplo animaba a las compañías chinas a
saltar al exterior y les prestaba todo
el dinero que hiciese falta ahora han
decidido que quieren lo contrario
el caso es que hoy si una compañía china
quiere comprar una extranjera necesita
la aprobación expresa del partido
comunista chino y a eso hay que sumar la
censura la inseguridad jurídica las
trabas al comercio la mala marca de los
productos chinos etcétera etcétera
vamos que podemos decir que hoy por hoy
salvo grandes errores propios el
liderazgo económico de eeuu no está en
peligro al menos en el corto plazo pero
como dije al principio este vídeo es
especial para nosotros porque enríquez
lo cuenta os dijimos que teníamos una
sorpresa pues bien os cuento un buen día
nuestro amigo ignacio de la plataforma
de autónomos y pequeños comerciantes de
ávila nos llamó y nos dijo hombre visual
político tiene que venir por habla así
que dicho y hecho
al fin y al cabo que mejor plan para una
escapada celtas romanos visigodos árabes
y castellanos todos han pasado por esta
ciudad patrimonio de la humanidad a la
que algunos han llegado a calificar como
la jerusalén de castilla fijaos qué
impresionantes
estamos ahora mismo en la puerta del
alcázar en la parte alta que estas eran
las defensas de la puerta esta de aquí
era para colocar el rastrillo esa reja
grande que caía de este agujero que
tenemos aquí en el suelo era para
colocar el caldero con agua hirviendo
para atacar a los que podían llevar el
ariete
[Música]
como veis amigos si os queréis sentir
cómodos y su amigo marty mcfly viajando
en el tiempo ávila es una gran opción
con sus leyendas y palacios con sus
condes sus reyes medievales y sus reinas
moras os garantizo que aquí os vais a
sentir como auténticos caballeros
medievales
pues bien amigos de visual político
desde esta fantástica ciudad que es
ávila nos despedimos como siempre si te
ha gustado el vídeo dale a like y no
olvides suscribirte al canal un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]